DESCRIBING WHAT HAPPENED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON JANUARY 6th.
I WILL NOW SWEAR IN OUR
WITNESSES.
OUR WITNESSES WILL PLEASE RISE
AND RAISE THEIR RIGHT HAND.
DO YOU SWEAR OR AFFIRM THAT THE
TESTIMONY YOU ARE ABOUT TO GIVE
IS THE TRUTH, THE WHOLE TRUTH
ANDIN
AND NOTHING BUT THE TRUTH, SO
HELP YOU GOD?
THANK YOU.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
LET THE RECORD REFLECT THAT THE
WITNESSES ANSWERED IN THE
AFFIRMATIVE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE
WITNESSES' FULL STATEMENT WILL
BE INCLUDED IN THE RECORD.
I NOW RECOGNIZE SERGEANT GONEL
TO SUMMARIZE HIS TESTIMONY.
>> GOOD MORNING, EVERYBODY.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> CHAIRMAN THOMPSON, MEMBERS OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE, THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
REGARDING THE ATTACK ON THE U.S.
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th, 2021.
IT IS WITH HONOR AND HEAVY HEART
THAT I COME BEFORE YOU TO TELL
YOU MY STORY, FROM A PAINFUL
FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE OF WHAT
HAPPENED THAT TERRIBLE DAY AT
THE CAPITOL.
PROVIDING THIS TESTIMONY SHOWS
MY PERSONAL CAPACITY AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE U.S.
CAPITOL.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT THE EVENTS
OF JANUARY 6 ARE FULLY
INVESTIGATED IN THE CONGRESS AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THE
TRUTH OF WHAT ACTUALLY OCCURRED
AND THAT ALL OF THOSE
RESPONSIBLE ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, PARTICULARLY TO
ENSURE THE HORRIFIC AND SHAMEFUL
EVENT IN OUR HISTORY NEVER
REPEATS ITSELF.
I IMPLORE YOU FOR PURSUING THIS
PERSPECTIVE.
EVEN THOUGH THERE IS
OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE TO THE CON
TERRI, INCLUDING HOURS AND HOURS
OF INDIVIDUALS AND PHOTOGRAPHIC
COVERAGE, THERE IS A CONTINUOUS
SHOCKING ATTEMPT TO IGNORE OR
TRY TO DESTROY THE TRUTH OF WHAT
TRULY HAPPENED THAT DAY.
AND TO WHITEWASH THE FACTS INTO
SOMETHING OTHER THAN WHAT THEY
ALL MISTAKENLY REVEAL, AN ATTACK
ON OUR DEMOCRACY BY A VIOLENT
DOMESTIC EXTREMISTS AND STAIN
OUR HISTORY AND OUR MORAL
STANDING HERE AT HOME AND
ABROAD.
AS A CHILD IN THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC, I LOOK UP TO THE
UNITED STATES AS THE LAND OF
OPPORTUNITY.
AND A PLACE TO BETTER MYSELF AND
FROM THAT MOMENT I LANDED AT
JFK, 1992, I HAVE TRIED TO
PURSUE GOAL.
THANKFULLY I ACHIEVED THAT GOAL
ON MANY LEVELS.
I WAS THE FIRST IN MY FAMILY TO
GRADUATE COLLEGE, JOIN THE ARMY
AND BECOME A POLICE OFFICER.
ON JULY 23rd, 1999, THE DAY
BEFORE MY 21st BIRTHDAY, I
RAISED MY HAND AND SWORE TO
PROTECT THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
BECAUSE THIS COUNTRY GAVE ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME ANYTHING
THAT I WANTED.
AT THAT TIME, I ALREADY STARTED
BASIC TRAINING WITH THE ARMY
RESERVES.
IN FACT, I RAISED MY HAND
SEVERAL TIMES IN CEREMONIES TO
PLEDGE MY COMMITMENT TO DEFEND
AND PROTECT THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES.
WHEN I JOINED THE ARMY RESERVES,
WHEN I WAS PROMOTED TO SERGEANT
IN THE ARMY, WHEN I WAS PROMOTED
DURING MY -- DURING MY CEREMONY
WHEN MY ENLISTMENT IN THE ARMY,
WHEN I JOINED THE UNITED STATES
CAPITOL POLICE AND LASTLY WHEN I
WAS PROMOTED TO SERGEANT THREE
YEARS AGO.
I ALWAYS TAKE MY OATH SERIOUSLY.
ON JANUARY 6th, 2021, I
FULFILLED MY OATH ONCE MORE.
THIS TIME TO DEFEND THE UNITED
STATES CAPITOL AND MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS CARRYING OUT THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTIES TO CERTIFY
THE RESULTS OF THE NOVEMBER 2020
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
TO BE HONEST, I DO NOT RECOGNIZE
MY FELLOW CITIZENS STORMED THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6 OR THE
UNITED STATES THAT THEY CLAIM TO
REPRESENT.
WHEN I WAS 25 YEARS OLD AND THEN
A SERGEANT IN THE ARMY, I HAD
BEEN DEPLOYED TO IRAQ FOR
OPERATION IRAQI FREEDOM.
FROM TIME TO TIME I VOLUNTEERED
TO TRAVEL ON IED INFESTED ROLLS
TO CONDUCT SUPPLY MISSIONS FOR
U.S. AND ALLIED FORCES IN LOCAL
IRAQI POPULATION AS WELL.
BUT ON JANUARY 6th, FOR THE
FIRST TIME, I WAS MORE AFRAID TO
WORK AT THE CAPITOL THAN IN MY
ENTIRE DEPLOYMENT TO IRAQ.
IN IRAQ, WE WERE IN A WAR ZONE.
BUT NOTHING IN MY EXPERIENCE IN
THE ARMY OR AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER PREPARED ME FOR WHAT WE
CONFRONTED ON JANUARY 6.
THE VERBAL ASSAULTS AND
DISRESPECT WE ENDURE FROM THE
RIOTS WERE BAD ENOUGH.
I WAS FALSELY ACCUSED OF
BETRAYING MY OATH OF TRUSTING MY
PAYCHECK, CHOOSING MY PAYCHECK
OVER THE LOYALTY TO THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION.
HERE AS I DEFENDED THE VERY
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS THAT
PROTECTED EVERYONE IN THE
HOSTILE CROWD.
WHILE I WAS AT THE LOWEST
TERRACE OF THE CAPITOL, WORKING
WITH MY FELLOW OFFICERS, TO
PREVENT THE BREACH AND RESTORE
ORDER, THE RIOTS CALLED ME
TRAITOR.
-- A POLICE OFFICER SHOULD BE
EXECUTED.
SOME OF THE RIOTERS HAD THE
AUDACITY TO TELL ME IT WAS
NOTHING PERSONAL.
THAT THEY WOULD GO THROUGH ME,
THROUGH US, POLICE OFFICERS TO
ACHIEVE THEIR GOAL AS THEY WERE
BREAKING METAL BARRIERS TO USE
AS A WEAPON AGAINST US.
OTHER USED MORE MENACING
LANGUAGE.
IF YOU SHOOT US, WE ALL HAVE
WEAPONS.
WE WILL SHOOT BACK.
OR WE'LL GET OUR GUNS, WE
OUTNUMBER YOU, THEY SAY.
JOIN US.
I HEARD SPECIFIC THREATS TO THE
LIVES OF SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
AND THEN ALSO VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE.
BUT THE PHYSICAL VIOLENCE WE
EXPERIENCED WAS HORRIFIC AND
DEVASTATING.
MY FELLOW OFFICERS AND I WERE
PUNCHED, KICKED, SHOVED, SPRAYED
WITH CHEMICAL IRRITANTS AND EVEN
BLINDED WITH EYE-DAMAGING LASERS
BY A VIOLENT MOB APPARENTLY WHO
SAW US, LAW ENFORCEMENT,
OFFICERS DEDICATED TO PROTECTING
THEM AS U.S. CITIZENS, AS AN
IMPEDIMENT TO THEIR ATTEMPT OF
INSURRECTION.
THE MOB HAD WEAPONS TO TRY TO
ACCOMPLISH THE INSURRECTION
OBJECTIVES AND USED THEM AGAINST
US.
THESE WEAPONS INCLUDED HAMMERS,
REBAR, KNIVES, BATON AND POLICE
SHIELDS TAKEN BY FORCE AS WELL
AS BEAR SPRAY AND PEPPER SPRAY.
SOME OF THE RIOTS WORE TACTICAL
GEAR INCLUDING BULLETPROOF VESTS
AND GAS MASKS.
THE RIDER TOOK OUR BAT ONES AND
SHIELDS TO USE THEM AGAINST US.
I WAS PARTICULARLY SHOCKED AT
THE SCENE THE INSURRECTIONISTS
VIOLENTLY ATTACKED US YOU WITH
THE VERY AMERICAN FLAG THAT THEY
CLAIM TO PROTECT.
BASED ON THE COORDINATING
TACTICS AND VERBAL COMMANDS WE
HEARD, IT APPEARS MANY OF THE
ATTACKERS HAD LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND MILITARY EXPERIENCE.
THE RIOTERS WERE VICIOUS AND
RELENTLESS.
WE FIND OURSELVES IN A VIOLENT
BATTLE DESPERATE TO ATTEMPT TO
PREVENT A BREACH OF THE CAPITOL
BY THE IMMIGRATION STAGE.
METROPOLITAN POLICE OFFICERS
WERE BEING PULLED INTO THE
CROWD.
WE HAVE ONE RIGHT HERE, RIGHT
NEXT TO ME.
AS WE TRY TO PUSH THE RIOTERS
BACK FROM THE BREACH IN THE
CAPITOL, IN MY ATTEMPT TO ASSIST
TO MPD OFFICERS AND ONE OFFICER
BY THE BACK OF THE COLLAR AND
PULL HIM BACK TO THE POLICE
LINE.
WHEN I TRIED TO HELP THE SECOND
OFFICER, I FELL ON TOP OF SOME
POLICE SHIELDS ON GROUND THAT
WERE SLIPPERY BECAUSE OF THE
PEPPER SPRAY AND BEAR SPRAY.
RIOTERS IMMEDIATELY BEGAN TO
PULL ME BY MY LEG, BY MY SHIELD,
BY MY STRAP ON MY LEFT SHOULDER.
I STARTED KICKING AND PUNCHING
AS I TRIED IN BANE TO GET
ATTENTION BEHIND AND ABOVE ME.
THEY COULD NOT HELP ME BECAUSE
THEY ALSO WERE BEING ATTACKED.
I FINALLY WAS ABLE TO HIT THE
RIOTER WHO WAS GRABBING ME WITH
MY BATON AND ABLE TO STAND AND
THEN I CONTINUED TO FEND OFF NEW
ATTACKERS AS THEY KEPT ROTATING
AND ATTACKING US AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
WHAT WE WERE SUBJECTED TO THAT
DAY WAS LIKE SOMETHING FROM A
MEDIEVAL BATTLE.
WE FOUGHT HAND TO HAND, INCH BY
INCH TO PREVENT AN INVASION OF
THE CAPITOL BY A VIOLENT MOB
INTENT ON SUBVERTING OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
MY FELLOW OFFICERS AND WERE
COMMITTED TO NOT LETTING ANY
RIOTS BREACH THE CAPITOL.
IT WAS A PROLONGED AND DESPERATE
STRUGGLE THAT RIOTER AS TEMPTED
TO BREACH THE CAPITOL WERE
SHOUTING TRUMP SENT US.
PICK THE RIGHT SIDE.
WE WANT TRUMP.
I HEARD OFFICERS SCREAMING IN
AGONY, IN PAIN JUST ALONG THE
LEFT OF ME.
I DIDN'T KNOW AT THAT TIME
I FINALLY FELL ASLEEP COMPLETELY
AND MENTALLY EXHAUSTED YET BY
8:00 A.M. I WAS ALREADY BACK ON
MY WAY BACK TO THE CAPITOL.
AND I CONTINUED TO WORK FOR 15
C
CONSECUTIVE DAYS UNTIL AFTER THE
INAUGURATION.
I MADE SURE TO WORK DESPITE MY
INJURIES BECAUSE I WANTED TO
CONTINUE DOING MY JOB AND HELP
SECURE THE CAPITOL COMPLEX.
MORE THAN SIX MONTHS LATER, I'M
STILL TRYING TO RECOVER FROM MY
INJURIES.
MANY OF MY FELLOW CAPITOL
OFFICERS AS WELL AS MPD OFFICERS
SUFFERED SEVERAL PHYSICAL
INJURIES FROM THE VIOLENCE
INFLICTED ON US ON JANUARY 6.
I SUSTAINED INJURIES ON BOTH MY
HANDS, MY LEFT SHOULDER, MY LEFT
CALF AND MY RIGHT FOOT.
I HAD SURGERY ON MY RIGHT FOOT
AND I WAS JUST TOLD THAT I NEED
SURGERY ON MY LEFT SHOULDER.
I'VE BEEN IN MEDICAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE FOR MUCH OF
THE PAST SIX MONTHS AND I EXPECT
TO NEED FURTHER REHAB FOR
POSSIBLY MORE THAN A YEAR.
THERE ARE SOME WHO EXPRESSED
OUTRAGE WHEN SOMEONE KNEELS
WHILE CALLING FOR SOCIAL
JUSTICE.
WHERE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE
EXPRESSING THE OUTRAGE TO
CONDEMN THE VIOLENCE ATTACK ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE CAPITOL, IN
OUR AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
I'M STILL WAITING FOR THEM.
AS AMERICAN AND THE -- WATCH IN
HORROR OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING AT
THE CAPITOL.
WE DID NOT RECEIVE TIMELY
REINFORCEMENT AND SUPPORT WE
NEEDED.
IN CONTRAST, DURING THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER PROTESTS LAST YEAR,
U.S. CAPITOL POLICE HAD ALL OF
THE SUPPORT WE NEEDED AND MORE.
WHY THE DIFFERENT RESPONSE, WHY
NOT FOR THE BRAVE MEMBERS OF MPD
AND LATER ON FROM OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
I'M AFRAID TO THINK WHAT COULD
HAVE HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th.
I WANT TO PUBLICLY THANK ALL OF
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THAT RESPONDED TO ASSIST THAT
DAY FOR THE COURAGE AND THEIR
SUPPORT.
I ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK THOSE
CAPITOL POLICE OFFICER WHO
RESPONDED ON THEIR OWN FROM HOME
AFTER WORKING THE NIGHT SHIFT.
DESPITE BEING OUTNUMBERED, WE
DID OUR JOB.
EVERY MEMBER OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, SENATORS AND
STAFF MEMBERS MADE IT HOME.
SADLY, AS A RESULT OF THAT DAY,
WE LOST OFFICERS.
SOME REALLY GOOD OFFICERS.
BUT WE HELD THE LINE TO PROTECT
OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
BECAUSE THE ALTERNATIVE WOULD
HAVE BEEN A DISASTER.
WE ARE NOT ASKING FOR MEDALS,
RECOGNITION, WE SIMPLY WANT
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
FOR MOST PEOPLE, JANUARY 6
HAPPENED FOR A FEW HOURS.
BEFORE, FOR THOSE OF US THAT
WERE IN THE THICK OF IT, IT HAS
NOT ENDED.
THAT DAY CONTINUED TO BE A
CONSTANT TRAUMA FOR US LITERALLY
EVERY DAY.
WHETHER BECAUSE OF OUR PHYSICAL
OR EMOTIONAL INJURIES OR BOTH.
WHY IT HAS NOT RECEIVED MUCH
ATTENTION, SADLY MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE QUIETLY RESIGNED
FROM THE CAPITOL BECAUSE OF THAT
DAY.
I'M ALSO REGULARLY CALLED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS AND
PROSECUTORS TO HELP IDENTIFY
FROM PHOTOGRAPH AND VIDEOS THE
RIOTERS.
AND TO BE HONEST, PHYSICAL
THERAPY IS PAINFUL AND HARD.
I COULD HAVE LOST MY LIFE THAT
DAY.
NOT ONCE, BUT MANY TIMES.
BUT AS SOON AS I RECOVERED FROM
MY INJURIES, I WILL CONTINUE
FORWARD AND PROUDLY SERVE MY
COUNTRY IN THE U.S. CAPITOL
POLICE.
AS MONEY IMMIGRANT TO THE UNITED
STATES, I'M PROUD TO DEFEND THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION AND OUR
DEMOCRACY ON JANUARY 6.
EVERYONE IN THE POSITION OF
AUTHORITY IN OUR COUNTRY HAS THE
COURAGE AND CONVICTION TO DO
THEIR PART BY INVESTIGATING WHAT
HAPPENED ON THAT TERRIBLE DAY
AND WHY.
THIS INVESTIGATION IS ESSENTIAL
TO OUR DEMOCRACY AND I'M DEEPLY
GRATEFUL TO YOU FOR UNDERTAKING
IT.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ASSIST AS I CAN
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTION YOU MAY
HAVE TO THE BEST OF MY ABILITY.
THANK YOU.
>> T